en el vídeo anterior cubrimos las bases
de lo que es una hipoteca de tasa
ajustable que es diferente de una
hipoteca de tasa fija pero seguramente
ustedes han escuchado un término que
parece ser una mezcla de estos dos y
esta es la hipoteca
hipoteca
de tasa ajustable
híbrida
y en general cuando mencionamos la
palabra híbrida quiere decir que es la
mezcla de dos cosas y esto es
exactamente lo que es una hipoteca de
tasa ajustable híbrida
es una mezcla
mezcla de la hipoteca de tasa ajustable
y la hipoteca de tasa fija
y a qué nos referimos con que es una
mezcla de la tasa ajustable y la tasa
fija quizás ustedes han escuchado un
término que es 5 a 1 de hipoteca de tasa
ajustable híbrida
qué significa esto bueno pues esto
significa que durante los primeros cinco
años esta hipoteca se va a comportar
como una hipoteca de tasa fija y después
de esos cinco años se comportará como
una taza ajustable en el ejemplo que
vimos en el vídeo anterior veamos que
conforme fluctúa va nuestra referencia
de la tasa de interés a un año pues cada
año nuestra hipoteca de tasa ajustable
se iba a redefinir si las tasas de
interés suben lo suficiente podrían
volverse desfavorables con respecto a la
tasa fija y eso es sólo para el
escenario que describimos aquí lo que
sucede con una hipoteca de tasa
ajustable híbrida de 5 a 1 es que
durante los primeros 5 años tendremos
una tasa fija
y una hipoteca de tasa fija
durante los primeros cinco años más o
menos por acá esto es fijo y después de
este tiempo se va a comenzar a ajustar
después de que pasan estos cinco años se
va a ajustar como si fuera una hipoteca
de tasa ajustable con las mismas
propiedades que vimos así que
comenzaremos a ajustarnos por lo que
aquí será nuestra nueva tasa de interés
para el año siguiente nuestra tasa de
interés estará más o menos por acá
recordamos que pagamos un porcentaje
extra del interés con base las tasas de
interés que tengan en ese momento los
bonos del tesoro a un año y la pregunta
aquí es bueno porque alguien querría
hacer esto porque el prestatario querría
hacerlo o porque el banco querría hacer
esto cuando hablamos de la hipoteca de
tasa ajustable también mencionamos esta
idea del riesgo de la tasa de interés en
una hipoteca de tasa ajustable el
prestatario es el que toma el riesgo de
la tasa de interés si la tasa de interés
aumenta el prestatario va a tener que
pagar más intereses
en cambio el prestamista estaría
protegido por otra parte en la tasa fija
aquí quien lleva el riesgo de la tasa de
interés es el prestamista y ahora el
prestatario es el que queda cubierto si
las tasas de interés aumentan el
prestamista es el que se lleva el riesgo
en cambio en el híbrido ambos quedan de
cierta manera en riesgo pero no tanto
durante los primeros cinco años el
prestatario estará cubierto ya sabe con
exactitud cuánto será el pago que tendrá
que hacer durante esos primeros cinco
años y después de esto se va a ajustar y
desde el punto de vista del prestamista
pues llevará el riesgo de la tasa de
interés durante los primeros cinco años
pero después ya que quizás sea difícil
de predecir cómo se comportarán las
tasas de interés después de cinco diez
quince o veinte años
entonces se comienza a ajustar y ahora
es el prestatario el que va a llevar el
riesgo de la tasa de interés y quizás no
se dé el caso de que el prestamista
tenga que tomar este riesgo podría darse
el caso de que el prestatario compre
otro tipo de propiedad que piensen que
van a vender la propiedad o incluso
puede que refinancia en esa propiedad si
ellos piensan que van a vender su
propiedad en los próximos cinco años
esto tendría mucho sentido especialmente
si se tiene una tasa baja de interés de
la que se hubiera obtenido con una tasa
fija por ejemplo podría ser que en la
tasa híbrida de interés estas personas
podrían haber obtenido una tasa de
interés más baja de hecho por el mismo
riesgo de tasa de interés podría ser que
hubieran obtenido una tasa del 3.5 y
después de cinco años más o menos por
aquí entonces ya se ajustaría la tasa
con respecto al índice usado aquí y este
sería más o menos por aquí ya que aquí
el banco está tomando menos riesgo de la
tasa de interés cuando llegamos más allá
del año 5 y es en este momento en el que
se hace el ajuste así pues si yo tengo
en mente que voy a vender esta casa
dentro de cinco años
financiera esta casa quiere decir que
voy a tomar otro préstamo para pagar
este préstamo si yo pienso que puede
hacer cualquiera de estas dos cosas
dentro de cinco años quizá tenga mucho
sentido que yo haga esto así que en el
híbrido ambas partes se turnan en tomar
el riesgo de la tasa de interés y
nuevamente dependiendo del escenario que
tengamos no estaría mal contemplar el
tener una hipoteca de tasa ajustable
híbrida ya que ustedes tengan la
confianza de que pueden solventar este
ajuste en la tasa de interés que
ocurrirá después del año 5 o que ustedes
consideren que esa es una propiedad de
la que son dueños y que podrían vender
dentro de 5 años o refinanciar o quizás
que la puedan pagar quizás ustedes están
esperando que puedan pagar el préstamo
en cinco años y de esta manera ya no
tendrán que preocuparse por los ajustes
que vengan después